[Music]
75 years ago today the ufo era came to
nevada in a dramatic way a military
pilot flying north of lake mead had a
close encounter with an unusual
formation it happened on the afternoon
of june 28 1947 the pilot saw a group of
five or six white circular objects
flying in a tight formation and
traveling at about 285 miles per hour
this came just four days after a more
famous sighting over mount rainier in
washington state that is the case
credited with starting the flying saucer
craze that swept across the country in
june of 1947. author preston dennis says
the military tried to explain away the
lake mead incident but they were in a
triangular formation and much closer
than regulations allow
so this clearly was unusual from the
get-go and as they observed it they saw
that these were not planes at all moving
really fast and uh they ended up
reporting this officially
and uh i believe
there's only four cases that actually
were declared unidentified by blue book
the lake mead incident is one of dozens
of notable ufo cases over nevada 8 news
now i-team reporter george knapp put
together a detailed history of the
nevada ufo incidents you can see those
on mysterywire.com